today I want just to think what would
happen if ice instead of floating on the
surface of water sank to the bottom
imagine in the winter when you'll pond
in your garden or in the park froze the
ice when it formed would go to the
bottom and then as more and more ice
built up the layer of ice at the bottom
would get thicker and thicker until in
the end the pond would be nearly totally
frozen and all the fish would be four
step on to the surface and would be
squirming around on the surface till
birds at them or fishermen just picked
them up or if you were at sea with a
nuclear submarine if the sea started
freezing it would be most embarrassing
your submarine could appear on the
surface of the ice and you'd be the
mercy of whoever you wanted from the
other way it is now except the fish
gradually gets squashed to the bottom as
it gets thicker and thicker now the ice
forms on the surface and when it forms
on the surface it forms quite a good
insulating layer and eventually if you
really aren't unlucky the ice could form
all the way down and squash the fish at
the bottom but that doesn't usually
happen because ice is a really very good
insulator and so most places unless it's
really cold like in the Antarctic or
somewhere like that there will be liquid
water at the bottom even in the
Antarctic there are underground lakes
that have recently been discovered where
there's liquid water right at the bottom
as you go deeper the pressure goes up
and when you go down at low depths the
pressure is higher and the melting point
of water actually goes down as the
pressure increases now the question is
why does it happen why does ice float on
the surface of the water
and the answer is that the water
molecules in ice are actually joined
together by so-called hydrogen bombs
these are bonds of oxygen hydrogen
oxygen and they are in a very regular
crystal structure when you melt ice
these bonds break not all of them but
quite a few of them so you still have
some of the water molecules joined
together but in a very random and the
haphazard way so instead of having a
very regular crystal structure with the
bonds between oxygen hydrogen and oxygen
they collapse and so the density gets
higher so ice is not very much lighter
than water but it's light enough to
float that's why just the tip of an
iceberg sticks out if ice was denser
than water icebergs would just fall to
the bottom of the sea you wouldn't have
the film Titanic it would have enormous
effects on our planet if ice did not
float because ice as you know is white
and so it reflects sunlight so when the
sea freezes and forms sea ice this
reflects back a lot of the radiation
from the Sun and particularly in areas
like the Arctic in summer where it's
daylight 24 hours a day the reflection
of the sun's radiation by sea ice is
really quite significant sea ice floats
particularly well because it is pure ice
but it is floating on salty water which
is denser than ordinary water and
therefore it is particularly buoyant if
you stop reflecting so much of the
sunlight that has implications for the
whole of the Earth's climate because
more radiation is absorbed by the earth
it will get warmer and therefore more
ice will melt and so
so if ice didn't float the our planet
would probably be a considerably warmer
place than it is now of course the place
where most people see floating ice are
in their drinks now it's quite important
when you drink at least particularly at
the beginning you drink from the top of
your glass so you want the first part of
your drink to be really nice and cold
and as you chat away and tell stories
and so on the glass goes down and so
you're always drinking from the surface
so if you put ice cubes into a drink and
they sink to the bottom you'd end up
with a warm drink and that would be a
social disaster alcohol pure alcohol is
much less dense than water and I just
have a feeling that if you take ordinary
ice and put it into pure alcohol it
would sink to the bottom we'll have to
try the experiment
we're in the vault the bullion vault of
the Bank of England and I'm really
excited I've never seen so much gold in
fact I've never seen so much of any
element